let's talk about some more strategy
today so make sure that your
when you play the game you're you're
familiar with ideas and what you need to
do okay
so let's start off with the very
important thing that we need to do when
we start the game the very first step is
to control the center okay now opponent
will respond with this move c5 this is a
very popular opening now and you have to
know what to do against this who knows
the name of this opening yes yes
Sicilian defense now white plays Knight
to f3
now d6 now in this opening usually you
want to get the control of the center
immediately so take pawn takes and I
want to show you this move that the most
people here take back with a knight they
go 90 X pawn that's what the most people
do but I want to talk about this move
here today a little bit Queen takes pawn
okay very interesting idea taking back
with the Queen how many people familiar
with this move have you seen this idea
before you are okay good the point of
this move is that you're developing more
pieces okay you'll now have more pieces
developed now he goes 96 attacking your
Queen the question is what you're going
to do now you're going to move it away
or you're going to do something else
here what would be the best move here
yes
you could but then you lose time also we
call the temples right by moving the
piece again you lose time and temples
something better you have here you don't
want to move the Queen here but if you
don't want to move the Queen here you
have only one move right correct and
that move wait Oh Julian wait what's the
move
excellent Bishop b5 this is called pin
it okay and what kind of pin is this
everybody it's a pin but what type of
pin is this Tigran Roy I don't know
Byron that's not sure about the real I
never heard that one about a pin but
what is this one called absolute pin why
is it's called absolute why at all right
because it's pinned to the king if it's
pinned to the King that's called
absolute pin if it's pinned to something
else
it's called pin but there's another name
to it you know relative pin of course
Archer yes relative pin so now he plays
Bishop d7 be careful okay don't blunder
your queen here and just castle I have
seen that happen people Castle and their
block just takes the Queen because there
is no longer a pin here no longer a pin
so if he goes there now what are we
going to do so we don't lose temples we
don't lose time what are we going to do
correct Bishop takes and now
you got to catch up on that development
right you got to get more pieces
developed here yes castle normally it's
good you could Casa but here white will
try to cast along this is a strategy
okay strategy against Sicilian defense
because if you play in a tournament
somebody opens up with Sicilian you
should know a little bit what to do
against it what to do white Bishop wait
it's white to move here whitens to move
we're here that's g5 that's that's gonna
you're gonna play that next move
remember in the opening what is the
strategy in opening nights before
bishops right to cram nice before
bishops so that means which one we gotta
play there you go everybody know that
concept night before bishops in the
opening most of the time you have to
follow that okay most of the time now he
goes here continue very good cause g6
and now you are in this position now
here this is what I was saying
don't rush with the cats because here
you have options you have choices to
Castle short or castle long which way
you're going to do it but you have to
also explain why you are doing the
particular move why you are doing that
particular move okay that's what you
have to explain as well yes
long castle why Arjun why long castle
very good process here very good thought
process castle you immediately put the
rook on a D file okay and you have
pressure on this immediately okay dye
goes Bishop e7 now you have to bring the
last piece into the game which piece
that would be yes perfect
the last stroke comes in here
now I bring the rook in now he castles
and now you put the King to safety
move the King away and now in this
position you have a very nice spawn here
you can just move your queen back to d3
with the idea to put the knight on d4
and continue with the idea of f4 f5 ok
that's a standard plum in this position
so let's say he will play six you put
the knight on d4 and then you continue
with the idea of f4 f5 okay so remember
that Lex is just general idea for you f4
and then you play a 5-2 attack on e6 and
if he captures you can take back with a
knight
and if you place the move e5 you can
simply capture Bishop captures you move
the knight here and you have a good
control here d5 squared and the d6
square is under attack so you can't
really do anything and now you put the
rook on e2 and knight on d5 okay
look on it - and the knight on d5 yeah
night goes on d5 and attacking the Queen
can't do anything now let's take a good
look at this position 17 moves and I
want to make sure you can remember this
okay to get this position so this is a
good system against Sicilian defense if
anybody opens up with that opening you
can definitely play this system so let's
go back so you can see get to this
position where he has a backward pawn on
d6 and you also have the control of the
d5 squash okay okay all right
let's start now let's put in a training
go ahead go ahead
first move
again everybody Sicilian defense is the
opening okay second move yes and now the
fourth move the captured the unusual
capture not the other capture yes Queen
takes correct now yes okay continue
excellent continue now you got to get
more development right more development
needed
yes
yeah
mm-hmm
now it goes here now remember you have
to make sure all your pieces are coming
in okay all of the pieces are in yes
look he1
castles and now can be won first and
then go in day three with idea to put
the knight on d4 and then you play f4 f5
to attack okay a six you know not yet
ninety-four first it goes here continue
for five okay don't rush about that
Bishop takes Knight each stakes and it
goes here and now you play a five
putting pressure okay you can also do
this idea with the King on c1 okay
that's another idea you know you can
also keep the King on c1 I just like to
put it there on b1 just to make sure
it's safe okay and then continue with it
because if it takes now you have nine f5
so he has to do this important you take
this and it goes here
and now you're going to go 95 look-see
to 95 and now night device
95 to have pressure night on day 5 the
backward pan on these six so this would
be a nice advantage for you okay against
the Sicilian Sicilian defense okay very
nice and comfortable position another
idea in this opening oftentimes I see
when they play e5 here okay this is not
a very good move because you can just
retreat to d3 square now Bishop e7 and
now my question to you is where do you
want to Castle again here Castle long or
castle short it's very good
absolutely
yeah castlelong because then immediately
you have pressure you immediately have
pressure now on the D file okay and if
you castles just you can put the King on
aside okay it goes here and now I need
you to simplify the position how you are
going to do that and we know material
wind material or really damage his
position his structure yes Bishop takes
f6 if it takes back this is terrible all
the pawns are weak and he can't really
do anything so he has to take back with
this and now if takes back with that now
he is going to drop what upon which one
I'm talking about
correct
Queen takes d6 Queen takes this six rook
text is six okay that's good position
away okay and if you move the Queen away
let's say to f5 you can even activate
the night I think you should actually
activate the Knight to d5 and cause some
problems for him out - okay so that's
that's what's going to happen if he
plays the move e5 so let's look at again
'if I've queen d3 Bishop e7
castles castles king b1 rook c8 and king
b1 rook c8 what is the idea
yes Bishop takes f6 perfect then you
winning pawns your question okay
alright if it takes you're just a pawn
and if he goes Queen a5 now you need to
activate which piece and that piece
belongs there right it belongs in the
middle of it
very good top very good Tata excellent
and now you ready to take one of his
bishops on f6 Bishop on f6 and all if he
takes on d5 then you just take back okay
very very good okay very very good okay
okay any questions no okay excellent
I have an example I want to set up for
you the team would be how to use the
open file okay it's not a checkmate so
don't look for a checkmate or anything
like that okay it's just the positional
idea here okay you are playing with the
white pieces in this position and you
have what we call in chess a slight
advantage here okay but not very you
know not very concrete slight advantage
because of that open file but you have a
very strong move here that will help you
to take this advantage further take it
further and try to win this game okay
now white to play and you need to find
the best move
because if you take my queen I take with
the king you don't have anything so it's
about let's put the hands down and think
for two minutes yeah this is a
grandmaster game okay this is a serious
players here so what to do here you want
to make sure somehow that you can get
your rook in the game as well very
actively now what to do what's the move
here so we can obtain the control of
that file or win some material here I
see a couple of hands here let's see now
black wants to actually take the Queen
and go to key seven and sort of
liquidate everything here so you have to
play a very subtle idea not at like a
simple move yes Queen a4 that's the
correct move very good yes white is
preparing to play which move rook
belongs on a seventh rank and the
problem for him is if it goes rook the
8th you take take take the pawn ok very
good idea
excellent
good
now he plays here a five now he plays a
five and we gotta get the rook where to
convey seven excellent Luke belongs on a
seven trying to remember that that's a
rule Brookes belong on a seventh now he
goes here his school is pretty active
now the active Queen needs to be what if
the opponent queen is too active it
needs to be exchanged okay so we hear we
need to find a way to exchange it okay
even though it may look like our
advantage is minimal but we just need to
exchange it we don't need to do anything
else yes perfect Queen to be five takes
takes now if they don't see it trying to
get active trying to get active now what
you're going to do you want to win the
b6 pun that's your pawn okay so what
you're going to do
Josh look p7 if he goes Roxy to actually
you just push a for preserve your pawn
keep it you go see you take it you goes
here you go here you take it
okay excellent tick tick take the pawn
and win the game
now rook c8
now he plays a four now what to do here
this is important because if you if you
just try to quickly take the pawn on b6
it's going to be a draw calculate
counting calculate remember count and
calculate at the end you need to have
two connected passed pounds to win this
one connected part one passed pawn not
going to do it you need two connected
passed pawns to win this yes no no but
if you do that then you leave the pawn
here isn't it better to take so the pawn
is not there any longer all right now he
goes here yes
perfect he takes excellent and now he
resigned here the you know sign but
let's try to understand why he resigned
because it may look like he could have
maybe play down if he exchanges you just
take that with a pond and you just
promote so he has to go here if it does
that you push okay but how are you going
to win this now what's the plan one punt
by pushing mom pond you're not going to
win it you have to push them together
together yes a four push now what's the
plan push now since your pond is
protecting the pond now you can move
your rock where are you going to move it
to so you can push continue click on
push now
which one you're going to push now what
should correct it now pants are
protecting each other what you're going
to do to promote let me move the rock up
there you go and now you're ready to
push the beep on and queen for the
victory
boom the ex takes okay any questions
yeah so remember that that's how you
have to do it okay
pushing your pants in order to Quinn so
let's start off this position again it
looks very close even for grand master
level this is like it looks very close
to a draw but it sounds clear you have a
question go ahead let's see how white
wins this again threatening rook d7 Rock
the eighth it's bad because you just
exchange and then at ten you pick up the
a seven-pound
continue
mm-hmm
if Roxy to just go a four and you just
take everything to connectors so he
plays a four and here you have to make
sure you don't blunder here because one
blunder here you're not winning this
okay continue
if he exchanges you just quit so it goes
here continue no
p6 he comes up here now get the ape on
it you just you push them together
together continuously together they go
in he goes here push
look here push push and now
excellent rook and you Quinn that's the
winning line you have a question all
right very good then
okay that's how you win this position
okay everybody okay good job today you
did very well
I liked the participation who everybody
was engaging and participating I was
very good now the second portion of the
class I'm going to pair you up with
people about your strengths okay so you
can play the game so you to continue
your game
you